how often do you write Oh that's a good
question people always say like how can
you be so disciplined to just sit in
your office and write all the time well
I don't write all the time if it's
artists and and but I would say if I
don't write it doesn't happen not like
only into an office and having a job and
and having specific tasks and things
like that and having meetings set up for
you I mean you know if you're if you
write a writing on TV staff is a little
different but if you basically writing
whether it's on spec or writing on
assignment and you're in your own space
you have to you have to get the work
done you have to create you know your
schedule so I find that when I'm on a
tighter deadlines I write much more I
write much faster I'm up earlier I up
later I certainly know a journal and
takes over where you just get it done if
I'm not in an assignment I'm writing
something for myself where I've got a
little time for something or I'm
preparing from needing this a week ago a
way instead of tomorrow I'll take a
little bit more time but basically every
day you know I'm always in work mode and
I'm always working on something writing
something putting pitches together
working on rewriting I always go back
and rewrite old scripts that I think
still have life in them that we can
maybe try to try to sell as scripts have
strange lives to them they have nine
lives in some respects because you can
write something and I have scripts I've
written 10 even 15 years ago that didn't
sell then but suddenly there's a reason
that something's out in the zeitgeist
now that if I just make some tweaks
instead of you know modernize it a
little bit or updated it may have a life
to it and I do that a lot
so when I have a little downtime I would
go back to the old scripts but I've I've
had a long I had to have had a long
stretch of a pretty regular assignment
work so that has kind of kept me in a
pretty you know pretty dedicated and
consistent work mode but you know I I
let's go this way I'm much happier and
much saner when I'm writing a lot you
know and free time free time is fine but
I do I just enjoy you know having having
that project that I'm working on so so I
try to write as much as I can when you
always get dedicated and structured I
mean
was that something overtime that
developed I've been I was been pretty
like whatever jobs I've had I've been
organized and even in school I was
organized you know not like you know
fanatically but you know I'm pretty good
it's sort of knowing how to get things
done in a quick way and not lose too
much time
you know prioritizing is very important
and because when you have a limited
amount of time to get something done you
really have to you have to kind of vote
be careful that you're not getting lost
in the minutiae of of things and really
stay focused on the bigger picture and
that overarching story and the bigger
structure of something then then playing
with every little word you can get soul
as a writer you can get so lost in the
in what someone I know once very
accurately called swirling the words you
know where you just you know you get the
script written and then you spend all
this time making every word perfect and
you know rearranging things and you know
we all want things to be as great as
what we consider perfect as possible but
then the movie gets made and there are
millions of changes along the way and
tons of things are cut and sometimes you
know what's being done sometimes you
don't know what's being done so you have
to really not over the course of time
I've learned to to really manage the
time I spend on things and not get too
caught up in the minutiae of things
which is kind of easy to do so but I'm
pretty good at organization and get
anything done and I'm fairly quick and I
can write fairly quick I can rewrite
fairly quickly over the course of time I
perseverate a lot less on honest on a
script or a story or a pitch I want it
to like I said I want it to be great but
I kind of I'm so good at letting things
breathe and evolve a little bit more to
get to the point that they need to be
how do you know if you're getting caught
up in the minutiae because I think as
creative people we think it's something
huge but really it's not I mean I was
very to get lost right you know
especially again if you're not on a
schedule you're not on a timetable or
you're not watching the clock it's very
easy to get lost now by the same token
I'm I'm a big believer like sometimes
you just have to just write stuff out
and just just you know have it in your
head and just get it down on the page
and not edit yourself to sort of you
know like like blow it out and I think
sometimes that's very helpful to get to
be to the essent to find the essence of
what you're really trying to do but I
think
quemo i think i think it comes just an
experiment with experience frankly i
think it's really just the more things
you've written and the more ways you
understand how to best tell and
structure a story so that it'll be the
most effective that it'll hit the marks
that somebody or somebodies hiring you
is looking for you know if you're
working for a film company or network or
producer who has certain paradigms
mandates things that work best for them
you know you focus on those things
because there's just some some when
you're writing for other people
sometimes there's so much you can of
yourself that can be in that script you
know you have you know you're trying to
try to fill a number of boxes and and
it's a little different than just
writing something on spec or like
writing a stage play which is which is
for you so you learn how to adjust the
amount of time you spend on things what
you focus on what is important what
probably less important what's going to
change was probably not going to change
because they have a finite amount of
time to do things
you